our shout out tonight is an update on
the great work done by a New York
reporter who helped give voice to some
high school students in Louisiana who
wanted to know why the predominantly
white high school in the same County had
so much better facilities than that
their school it got the attention of the
federal judge overseeing the district
who had no idea what was going on until
he saw the report the mold the carpet
the walls itself the classrooms the
teachers everything that you need in the
school or could use in the school he's
not there
reporter Dan Lieberman the online media
outlet now this went to Quetta hula
parish in Louisiana two block high
school where most of the students are
African American to see why students are
speaking out in what conditions and deep
south schools are like more than six
decades after desegregation we saw a
local news piece from rural Louisiana
about these kids were protesting the
conditions at their high school i talked
with lieberman at the novice studios in
new york where the kids afraid to speak
out where they afraid they might be
punished by the school they were
surprised to see that that someone from
out of town out of state was showing up
to really put a spotlight on these
issues they weren't sure it was going to
make much of a difference because they
really felt like in this parish in this
state their their voices didn't matter
and they weren't going to get a change
what made the story so powerful is what
Lieberman then discovered nearby but 13
miles away there's another school in the
same school district that looks a lot
different nearly 90% of the senior class
here is white they perform better
academically
and enroll in college at a higher rate
it really did feel wrong it felt like an
injustice this is one School District
the schools should not look that
different and that you know there's been
desegregation orders in place since the
1960s and for you know if you're in
eleventh and twelfth grade at one school
majority-white
other school majority-black you look at
the conditions of the two high schools
and and you see that the funding doesn't
add up so we just tried to film inside
Harrisonburg high school but the
superintendent won't let our cameras
inside they don't want the principal's
to talk to us on camera but there's a
clear notable difference in how the
school looks compared to black high
school but Lieberman was able to get the
superintendent on camera when we talked
to students and we talked to families at
black high school they compared it to
Harrisonburg they say Harrisonburg has
beautiful facilities why do you think
they're saying there's such a difference
several of the other schools communities
of past Bondi she's specifically around
facility renovation and refurbishment
and in the recent years Johnsville
hasn't passed any such issue to address
their schools both high schools are in
the same district and Lieberman says he
thinks there's more to it than bond
issues after talking to one school board
member so I asked the school board
member why don't you just consolidate
the schools and she said the parents at
that school they don't want their kids
going to school with those kids because
of their moral character that's what she
said yeah when it was what a big load
for because it's a code for racism it's
it and it it was so it was so obvious
you feel it there and it was wrong
Lee Berman's report had immediate impact
federal judge Dedra
overseeing the long delayed
desegregation efforts in that school
district saw the now this report and
ordered a hearing into what's going on
so essentially he was unaware of this
disparity until your report that's right
so he gave you full credit for bringing
this to his
neither the school board nor the Justice
Department had done that he said I'm he
said that I'm so glad you came down
Louisiana why do you think it took an
outsider to go down there and to reveal
this to me I really think that it speaks
to the broader crisis in journalism
where areas like this in the deep south
in rural areas they're not getting asked
tough questions reporters are not
showing up they're asking tough
questions since that original report Dan
Lieberman tells us the high school
principal and the superintendent are
both out of jobs one resigned the other
retired and now the federal judge
overseen though long delayed
desegregation efforts has ordered school
officials to report back to him every
other month about what's being done to
correct this glaring black-white
discrepancy good work Dan well that's
our program for tonight thanks so much
for joining us we'll see you back here
next week good night